u.s and its allies withdrawal from
afghanistan has led to a new crisis and
it's still unclear how this will affect
regional and global security
that's why
it is for good reason that our countries
have paid special attention to this
issue
evidently russia just like its brick
partners has consistently spoken for
establishing a long-awaited peace and
stability on the afghan soil
the citizens of this country have fought
for decades and deserve to exercise the
right of defining what their state will
look like on their own
meanwhile we are all interested in
afghanistan's
ceasing to be a threat to the neighbors
so that the afghan territory
would
be a source of drug trafficking and
terrorism we are interested in still
paying migration flows
we are for afghans living in peace and
dignity on their soil i have said on
numerous occasions that a new spiral of
crisis in afghanistan stems directly
from irresponsible attempts to impose
alien values from the outside and
intention to build the so-called
democracy
democratic structures
using
the patterns and methods of social and
political engineering without taking
into account either historic features
and disregarding
the traditions that other people's
people have followed
it results in destabilization and chaos
and after that the authors of these
experiments back down
leaving those they have paternalized
their own devices
and
the entire international community will
have to clear up the mass as a result
i'm confident that we can ensure
progressive development of the
international relations only through
guaranteeing the coexistence of states
with different political and social
systems
their own national interests and
spiritual and moral values
however we must strictly observe the
fundamental principles of international
law enshrined in the u.n charter
including non-interference into the
internal affairs and respect for
sovereignty it is also important
to support and develop internationally
the interaction based on mutual respect
and constructive and effective approach
to strengthen the emerging multipolar
system including independent centers of
economic growth and political influence
which the brics
is
definitely a part of
you